hey guys I'm just McDonald it in the
18th off every and you're tuned into
games got news all right so I've got yet
more resolution used to kick you off
today but it's idols Montreal telling
you not to stress that these is coming
to Xbox one at 900p so that's a few p
less than its competitor since the ps4
is running the sneaky adventure at 1080p
I just want real is saying that it's so
not a big deal first up both versions
will be running at 30fps and fifth game
director Nicholas Canton says he can't
tell the difference in fact a bunch of
people in the dev team agreed that the
two versions are almost identical when
running side-by-side if you'd like to
nitpick over the word almost then be my
guest Canton goes on to confirm that the
slightly lower resolution will have no
effect on the gameplay and that he
thinks the resolution argument is
getting way too big to which I say one
of us and that's your daily resolution
update all wrapped up in the only story
that i had an audible reaction to
reading today rational games is shutting
down co-founder ken Levine revealed the
closure today and says he is planning to
embark on a new smaller endeavor for
parent company take two interactive
although this is set to put all that
fifteen staffers out of a job Levine
says his new plan is to make
narrative-driven games for the core
gamer that are highly replayable so
Bioshock I guess he's also indicated
that he'll be distributing his new
mystery projects digitally le vine has
expressed his excitement for his new
team structure and returning to where
irrational started with a design games
the core gaming audience with a small
team since this means Bioshock is out of
his hands are you concerned for the
future of the series or are you just
interested to see what he'll come up
with next last off the mark today the
ps4 has sold a bunch a serious punch the
latest figures indicate 5.3 million have
now been sold worldwide which means
Sony's forecasts of selling five million
by the end of March has been pretty
comfortably surpassed the company is
pretty set to see a healthy jump in
these sales fairly soon too
the console launches in japan on the
twenty-second of this month as you can
imagine sony is having a field day but
let me know if you picked yourself up
NEX gen console and which one you
decided to go for you can leave me your
thoughts in the comments down below or
on my Twitter where I'm at just McDonald
that's all I got for you today in terms
of the good the bad and the resolution
II but be sure to check back with me
again tomorrow for more news I'll see
you sing